[Music]
welcome to brainstorm design at the
beginning was kind of the aha moment and
for me what design means to business
design has been a way to scale the
probability of excellent albums good
design is good business it's a simple
eloquent statement what is design
thinking it is just very simply bringing
the way of thinking of a designer to a
broader set of problems how business
executives fully embrace design as a
strategy design thing in is part of the
equation to me that's the strategic
thing you that's the plan that you make
when design is a route to innovation we
don't care about design in it of itself
at least in business organizations we
care about design because it allows us
to create better value for people so
science informed engineering which
informs art which is forms design and
they interact among them and the
production of real constructive thing
can happen there
making the most light reflective
material which is out there inspired by
the wing of a butterfly no battery no
LED no cables no wires no solar panels
just the headlights of the car and when
there are no cars there's no light no
light pollution in a way this is like a
gentle mountain of trades so each team
is on their own level there hopefully
you can get the chemistry of a team
working with themselves and the
separation from another team but also
the collective power of feeling being in
a space within a few months this is
going to be the roof of a carport and
then it'll be the roof of the high-end
residence and then maybe it'll be a
chunk of a museum and each one of those
will be better than the last
one hack which was take a cheap ikea
bowl and make yourself a cheap Tom Dixon
lamp by drilling a hole in it and hang
you upside down I thought was a such a
fabulous idea defining what is good and
bad design changes constantly in
different times and in different
contexts we really need to think more
about our social responsibility
companies are implementing new
technology and new strategies to really
win the loyalty of their customers -
I've come to sectional designers
emotional designers all these new types
of design are going to deliberate as we
start with you a AIA and then Dadar and
connected the Fonz's we have a phrase at
Facebook that were really at the very
very tip of the iceberg I want to thank
all of you it's been a great three days
we look forward to seeing you next year
[Music]